[Music]
Will Smith keeping a low profile in Los
Angeles on Oscar Sunday one year after
he made headlines for slapping Chris
Rock during the 2022 ceremony
oh wow I am deeply devoted and committed
to putting light and love and joy into
the world photok spotted the actor out
at about around 4 pm roughly an hour
before this moment aired why don't you
have fun we want you to feel safe and
most importantly we want me to feel safe
so we have strict policies in place if
anyone in this theater commits an act of
violence at any point during the show
you will be awarded the Oscar for best
actor
permitted to give a 19-minute long
speech yeah within the within the few
minutes of Sunday's show host Jimmy
Kimmel referenced the slap scene round
the world you know he can't it's the
elephant in the room he can't there's an
elephant in the room you have to say hey
look at that it's an elephant no but
seriously the academy has a crisis team
in place if anything unpredictable or
violent happens during the ceremony just
do what you did last year nothing
sit there and do absolutely nothing
maybe even give the assailant a hug
and if any of you get mad at a joke and
decide you want to come up here and get
jiggy with it
it's not going to be easy you're going
to get have to get through the
heavyweight champ Adonis Creed before
you get to me
yeah nobody's gonna hit me I'll run if
somebody comes up on stage and I'm
pretty fast so I think I'm going to be
okay the academy banned will from
attending this year's show he actually
can't go for another nine years pretty
much unheard of when it comes to a best
actor winner there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to behave in that moment we'll release
that emotional apology video months
after the incident which is still making
headlines thanks in part to Chris
speaking out in his new Netflix special
everybody
knows yes it happened I got smell like a
year ago last week I've got smacked in
the Oscars by this
people like didn't hurt it still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears
The Source tells E.T Will's embarrassed
and hurt by what the comedian said he's
upset that Netflix gave Chris a platform
calling it distasteful because I have
rooted for Will Smith my whole life I
root for this okay and now I I watch
emancipation just to see him get whooped
The Source adds that Wills worked on
himself and wants Chris to move on so
that he and everyone else can too
[Music]
thank you